Winston Churchill see this applies to
you in this what you're doing has a
famous saying that I quote in a
different context which is above my life
which is success is going from failure
to failure but with enthusiasm doesn't
apply in this space that's it that's a
great quote we you have to have
enthusiasm you know you have to as a as
an entrepreneur which is what I've been
most of my life you're running on
enthusiasm you know you need to stand up
in front of a group of people and tell
them that the company is really going to
be fantastic and then you go home and
die and you cry and you hope that it's
really going to make so you have to you
know and I think by nature we both are
enthusiastic people and you need to have
failures if you haven't failed then you
haven't learned and or maybe that's
centric if you failed it doesn't
necessarily mean you learned if you you
know and we fail often but hopefully
when we fail the next failure is it's
not the same way and we have learned
from the first failure oh yeah and we
actually even have code names you know
if we did something and it failed the
next time something comes up we'll say
amongst the three of us or amongst the
investment team oh yeah that's like a
blah blah blah okay we'll stay away from
that so you you need to fail I think
failure and risk are really important
and that's the way that things grow if
not we're just all going to be in a
fairly steady state do you think that
particular way of thinking about failure
comes from your entrepreneurial
background and is that different then
then then people who have been engaged
in a different kind of philanthropy or
came at philanthropy from an inheritor
perspective yes it's very different
because our wealth was created by taking
personal risks and career risks and
acting a certain way for 15 or 20 years
in our professional career and we had a
lot of luck and success in fate and it
worked and so that model worked for us
and so we're actually using that same
model in in our philanthropy
if it's a and we could do that because
it's the Betsy and Jesse Fink foundation
and we are you know we can make those
decisions we abide by all the rules and
guidelines need to happen but there's
not a lot of bureaucracy in fact
whenever we feel like there's some
bureaucracy creeping into our small
little foundation it's just it makes us
nervous and we need to figure how to do
it we do have good governance and so I
think we have great reports and great
accountability but we like to keep it
small other foundations that are second
generation or third generation that the
founders of that the creators of the
wealth or not there are in a very
different situation in that case they
have a different responsibilities to be
more of the stewards of that wealth and
make sure that they're following
whatever was written down as the
guidelines for the philanthropy on how
they're going to distribute that for us
we wrote things down but we can change
it we can change it every year we look
at and say what are the issues the sub
issues that we want to focus on this
year okay how are we going to do that
it's just we we are able to run our
organization a lot more fluidly and
entrepreneur because that's that's who
we are at the stage 20 years from now
are our foundation if it's still if we
haven't given it all away we'll be in a
different different situation